well you need to contemplate your own
malevolence because that helps you
understand who you are and who you could
be and you could be something absolutely
brutal and terrible so you need to
contemplate your own malevolence so that
you understand who you are and that
means you have to contemplate
malevolence as such because you're not
only who you are you're who you could be
for better or worse and I actually think
it's I think it's a lot easier to start
to understand who you could be if you
were better if you deeply understand who
you could be if you were worse and who
you might be to the degree that you're
blind to that worse presently so you
think oh my God I could be that
malevolent a force for ill that's
horrible but highly compelling and
plausible given my understanding of my
own character